Now, before we go further,
I want to talk about our player controller
because we're going to actually be creating
a brand new player controller
for this interaction logic to go into.
And the reason for this is because we want the player,
no matter if it's a player or a car
or a spaceship or a ball,
to be able to press the E key on their keyboard
and be able to interact with this light switch.
And this is a really key importance
of building things inside of Unreal.
We always want to make sure that we build stuff
in the correct location.
Now we could build all of this functionality
that we're building in each one of these classes.
We could build it inside of our player,
inside of our car, inside of our spaceship
or inside of our ball.
But that means that there are now four locations
where we need to maintain our code.
Since the player controller acts as a way
to take different pawns over,
while still giving the user the same type of input
based off the device they're using,
we can input code or implement code
inside of our player controller
and have that accessible to the user
no matter the type of pawn that they are.
So let's go ahead and pop over here
to the editor really quick.
And I'm gonna hit control space
and we're going to right click inside of here.
We're gonna go to our blueprint class.
And then from our pick parent class,
we're gonna look for our player controller.
I'm gonna call this BP underscore
interaction, interaction controller.
Let's go ahead and double click on it to open it up.
Now to understand what we're gonna do next,
let's take a look at the following image.
So what we're gonna be doing
is we are going to be creating a line in space.
And that line is going to start
in the center of our character.
And it's gonna go out at X distance that we define.
And anything that is inside of that line,
we can determine different properties about it.
And for us, what we're gonna be doing
is we're gonna be casting this line
X unit out into space.
And we're gonna see if that line comes in contact
with an object that contains our interface.
And if it does,
then we'll be able to do something with it.
So again, this is an example here,
a visual example of what we're gonna be creating.
We're gonna be creating a line that goes out into 3D space
that starts at our player's center and has an end point.
And we were gonna use this to determine
if we are looking at a light switch or not.
So here's a breakdown of the nodes
that we're gonna be using.
So we're gonna use our input action interact
as our trigger.
Then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna use a combination of our get actor location,
our get controlled pawn and our get actor forward vector
to determine the location and the rotation
that the player is currently facing in the world.
And we're gonna use that
inside of our line trace by channel node.
And we're gonna use this
to give us a start and an ending value.
And once we've done that,
we can then do things off of our out hit,
which we'll describe here in just a little bit.
So let's go ahead and come over to the editor now.
And we're gonna come over to our event graph
and let's go ahead and start adding stuff.
So first things first,
we're gonna look for our IA underscore
and look at that, we have our IA interact.
So that's the first thing that we want right there.
All right, so then we're gonna look for our get actor
and we probably gonna have to disable
our context sensitivity.
There we go.
We wanna transform a get actor location.
Then we're gonna look for our get controlled
and we want this get controlled pawn.
So there we go.
And I'm actually just gonna delete these
cause we don't need them right now.
And then we're going to get actor forward
and we want this transformation get actor forward vector.
Then what we're gonna do
is I'm gonna pull this over just a little bit
cause I don't need that big of a details panel.
We're gonna look for our line trace by channel.
There we go.
There's our line trace by channel.
And then what we're gonna do is
we are going to need a couple of multiplications.
And one of the things that we can do here
is we can just add this multiply
and we can actually right click on these
and change their inputs.
So we're gonna do this in just a second here.
I'm gonna hit control C and control V
because I wanna pop back over to our slide deck here
to show you kind of what we're gonna be setting up.
So here's what we're gonna do.
When the user does the interact, when that's triggered,
what we're gonna do is we're gonna get our controlled pawn.
We're gonna get its location and its forward vector.
And then basically we're gonna take the location
that it's at as our start.
So at the beginning of our line trace.
And then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take the forward vector.
We're gonna multiply that by a float value, say 2000.
And then we're gonna multiply that by the actor location.
And this is going to act as the end of our line trace.
So this value right here, which is set to 2000
is basically the distance at which we want
this interaction to happen
because we don't want it to go infinitely across the world
because that means that somebody could turn
the light switch on from all the way across the room.
No, we want them to be relatively close to it.
So let's go ahead and set this up now.
And we're gonna pop over here to the editor.
So the other cool thing about this
is this is the basic logic for anytime you wanna do
a line trace inside of Unreal.
So if you ever want to do a line trace ever again,
following this will get you set up
and a way that will be successful
pretty much every single time.
So let's grab our controlled pawn.
And again, this has to go into our get actor location
and get actor forward vector.
So oops, we'll plug that in right there.
So again, we want our get actor location.
That's gonna be the start of this.
And then what we're gonna do
is I'm gonna pull one of these over here.
Actually we need both of those.
So we're gonna bring both of them here.
So what we're gonna do is we are gonna take
the return value here and plug that in like so.
But instead of that being multiplied in each channel,
we want this by a float.
So we're just gonna click on this
and we're gonna go to float single precision.
There we go.
And we're gonna do two, one, two, three.
So by 2000.
And then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take our get actor location.
We're going to multiply it by this offset value.
And then we're gonna plug that in to our end right there.
Now, the next thing that we can do here
is if we come here to this debug draw type
and we can go for duration to compile and save.
What that's gonna do right there
is it is going to allow us to see the line
that is traced in the world.
So let's go ahead and look at what we're gonna do last.
So the last thing that we're gonna do here
is on our out hit, which is,
we can have this special node called break hit result.
What this will do is this will allow us
to do very specific things
when very specific conditions are met.
So for us, when we hit an actor,
we are going to do a test.
Does it, does object implement interface?
And we're gonna see,
does this object that we have hit with our line trace
implement our BPI usable interface?
And if it does,
then we are gonna send a message use objects.
So let's go ahead and set that up now.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna come out of here
and we're gonna look for our break hit,
break hit results.
And we can actually get more information
by pushing this triangle here.
And we're gonna see all of the different things
that we have inside of here.
So we're gonna take our out hit
and plug that in right here.
And then what we're gonna do
is we're gonna pull off of our hit actor
and we're gonna look for does implement.
And we're gonna say, does object implement interface.
And the interface that we want it to check for
is BPI underscore usable.
We want to check to see if we've hit our usable.
Then one of the other cool things we can do
is if we push this little button again,
we will collapse that back up
so that we get this nice little smaller node
just with the thing that we have there.
And I'm just gonna right click and straighten that.
All right, so the next thing that we need to do
is we need to come out of our line trace by channel
and we need to actually do something.
So what we're gonna do
is we're gonna left click and drag off of this
and we're gonna look for our branch node.
Just remember branch is Unreal's if else.
I'm also gonna double click on this
just to add a reroute
and kind of just move this line up a little bit.
You don't have to do that,
just kind of makes things a little bit easier to read.
So when we do interact with an object,
we're gonna test and we wanna do something
if this is true.
And what do we wanna do?
Well, we want to use object
and we want this use object right here.
Oops, nope, that was the wrong one, sorry.
Let's put on context sensitivity again
and we'll go use object.
Let's do that one more time, there we go.
Use and there we go.
We want that one right there.
All right, and last but not least,
we do need to come out of this hit actor here
and this is gonna be the target.
So the actor that we've actually hit
and I'm also gonna double click on this
to bring this over here like so
and just like this, kaboom, there we go.
All right, so I did show you
this last little part right here, our for duration.
What this is gonna do is this is going to allow us
to see our line trace like we see in the image right here
Now, if we were to come over here to our editor
and try this out, let's just press play really quick.
Nothing is going to happen.
So you can see it does say hello.
The reason for this is because if we come over here
to our game mode, we need to put our player controller class
that we have here in that game mode.
So let's go ahead and pop back to our editor here
and we're gonna come here to our world settings.
If you don't see the world settings,
you can come up to your window
and then go down to not world partition,
but world settings that will populate this window.
And then under our game mode here,
we're gonna come to our player controller class
and we're gonna look for my BPI interaction controller.
Now, once I press play, what should happen
is we should get this red line coming out
and the little square that you're seeing right there
that signifies where this object actually first made a hit
and then the green line that you're seeing
is what it is penetrated to.
So the red is the first line,
the green is the second line.
So what hit has gone through if it has penetrated.
All right, so now that we have that set up and working,
what we're gonna do next
is we are gonna set up our light blueprint.